On June 24, Turks go to the polls to elect
a president and parliament.
Six presidential candidates are running, including
incumbent, Recep Tayyip Erdogan.
Challengers have voiced radically different
visions and some polls say elections are too
close to call.
Erdogan should be in trouble: Turkey’s currency
is in free fall and Turkish military operations
in both Syria and Iraq have floundered.
But does this matter?
The days of free and fair elections in Turkey
are over.
Erdogan rules as a dictator under a state
of emergency.
He has imprisoned charismatic Kurdish candidate
Selahettin Demirtas.
Mayors loyal to Erdogan block opposition campaigning.
Erdogan formed his own militia to beat up
challengers,
and a viral video shows Erdogan telling supporters
to prevent opposition from voting.
Turkish politicians say the margin of fraud
and cheating is at least 5 percent, so any
challenger needs to win at least 55 percent
and even that’s no guarantee Erdogan would
step down.
There are open questions: Will elections go
to a second round?
How many parties will enter parliament?
But to consider Turkey a democracy is to believe
in unicorns.
There is now only one certainty: Erdogan will
rule Turkey until he dies.
What do you think about Turkey's election and Turkey's future?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.